seo is an important part of the
marketing strategy
in case your website doesn't show up on
the first page of the search engine
then you need to work on it to solve all
your seo related problems
we have come up with a solution welcome
to simply learn's youtube channel and
today we will be discussing
the top 10 tips that every marketer
needs to know
in the year 2021 so let's get started
and see our first step the first step we
have
is the voice search voice search will
impact
search queries in 2021. according to
dialoguetech.com
the united states of america 55
of the households will have their own
smart speaker by
2022 well that's a lot in that case
if you are planning to optimize your
voice search consider choosing
wise keywords find out longer phrases
that searchers use in daily life
conversation
voice search is more suitable way for
searching long and
more natural sounding phases creating
detailed and relevant
answers are essential when optimizing
for voice search
so always remember to create a persona
based content
next create web pages that can answer
faq use
because when searchers ask a question
they begin their question with words
like
who when what however there are many
reasons for using
voice search such as dictating text
messages
looking for a video on youtube calling a
person from your contact list
asking for directions etc
according to forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience
due to its extensive use search engines
such as google are focusing on voice
search optimization
google's voice search shows websites on
top that
load quickly in that case you must
always ensure that your website has a
responsive design
its images are optimized the files are
compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve
page speed and finally the last
important point
your server's responsive time is reduced
so followed by the first step the second
one is
the mobile optimization you must already
know how
important is it to make your site mobile
friendly for a better user experience
but did you also know that having a
mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization
sem rush confirms that by the year 2025
approximately 73 percent of internet
users
will access the internet through mobile
devices
google's mobile friendly update has
resulted in a big change in search
rankings
with the help of google's free mobile
friendly test
have a look at how effective mobile
website is
also take a peek at mobile usability
report in
google search console now let's talk
about
the tip number three that is google's
eight principles
google has confirmed that content
quality is an essential factor for
ranking on search engine result pages
but what does the quality mean to google
well content that fulfills the google
eat principle
will rank higher it stands for expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
these elements will determine if a
webpage has useful quality content
google uses the combination of
algorithms to deliver the best results
for users
google panda is one of the famous
algorithms of google
which emphasizes delivering high quality
content
it removes web pages from index that
have low quality and duplicate content
not just that there is one more
algorithm called
rank brain rank brain is an algorithm
that uses
artificial intelligence to interpret
search queries
that audience search on google whereas
the search query may not have the right
keywords
that were searched for for example when
you search for chocolate cake recipes
you will also get results for chocolate
truffle cake recipes
on the search engine result pages google
panda
and rankbrain send bots to crawl each
and every website
and as a result shows high quality
content on the top of the search engine
results page
next is our tip number four featured
snippet these results are featured on
top part of the page
google programmatically chooses the best
answer from the third party website
and displays it on the featured snippet
here's how a featured snippet
looks like according to ahrefs a
specific search query
almost 99 of web pages shown in the
featured snippet already rank on
serp's first page some of the ways to
optimize
feature snippets are organize your
content in a structured way
make sure one article answers many
similar questions use eye catchy images
and the last point create answers with
tables to drive clicks
and write dedicated headings to answer
featured snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create snippets
plan on creating question based
questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at
google search function that is usually
written in blue color
and it reads out as people also ask
now let's move into the fifth tip
image optimization according to sem rush
image optimization will play a prominent
role in search
in case the images on your website
aren't optimized
make sure to take care of it right now
remember to use
high quality images relevant images and
use a suitable label for your image file
include images in your site map as it
becomes
easier for the bots to crawl and finally
use alt tags as crawlers use it to
classify the images
alt text is displayed on the web page
when an image
fails to load on a user screen it is
also utilized by google to drive
meaning from images a well optimized
image can improve your page ranking and
increase the engagement on it
image optimization can help your web
page show the image keroses
on search engines next we have
semantically related keywords semantic
search
will have become an important factor for
ranking in the future
semantic keywords are linked to the
primary keywords
they drive relevant traffic on search
engine result pages
a simple way to look for lsi keywords
is on google serp semantic
search can be performed wisely by
writing content that targets
the question that your target audience
is looking for
remember to optimize content for topic
clusters
instead of focusing solely on keywords
and finally
use structured data and pick your
semantic keywords
this can also be done with the help of a
comprehensive keyword
tool it finds out semantically related
keywords
next comes our tip number seven building
quality
links building quality links to your
website
is important if you are aiming to manage
a successful
and long-term seo strategy building
quality links
can't be ignored in 2016
google declared that building quality
links are one of their top three ranking
signals always
opt for quality over quantity as
building
quality links to your content can give
your product
and category pages a boost in serps
let me share you a few effective
strategies that will increase the number
of links
pointing to your website dramatically
first one earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages
next promote your content regularly on
social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing
next take advantage of social media
platforms like
facebook twitter instagram and
start your own page then participate in
forums
to engage with your target audience
start your blog and attract your target
audience
with your valuable content finally get
listed in the high quality link
directories
this will help you build links from
authoritative websites
next number eight is local search
listings local seo is the practice of
optimizing a website in order to obtain
traffic from location-based
searching it is the best way to market
your products and services to local
customers
according to google local results are
based on relevance
distance and prominence these factors
help google to find the best match for
your search
due to this reason it becomes important
to have your
nap details accurate and consistent
across the internet sem rush confirms
that
local search listings will play a larger
role in the seo strategies
suppose you want to know how to get your
business into the local pack
go to google my business page and create
your own
for this it is also important to have
strong
backlink profile next we have the number
nine
that is improve the user experience for
a past
few years ux has become an important
ranking factor
for google however more
and more seo specialists have gained an
interest in ux
ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor
consider the partnership of search
engine optimization and
user experience this way the search
engine
optimization focuses on search engines
and
user experience targets website visitors
so both share a common goal of giving
users
the best result this is what the content
king app says about the user experience
let me show you a few practices on how
effectively leverage ux designs to
provide
your site's seo performance
simplify your site's navigation a good
site architecture
helps to gain traffic utilize ux design
to seo friendly layouts
which means make content easy to digest
infused images and videos whenever
possible
use ctas very wisely
and finally optimize for site load speed
optimize for mobile responsive design as
more than 50 percent of all the traffic
is now driven by
mobile search in case your site isn't
mobile responsive
you will notice poor engagement and
finally
we come at our 10th and last tip
that is using schema markup
according to search metrics 36 percent
of search keywords bring up at least
one feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup
schema markup is a micro data that every
individual can add to his website in
order to give an enhanced description
to users on a search engine results page
in simple words
schema markup is used to define website
content adding structured data
will give your website a significant seo
boost and increase your rankings some of
the schema markup examples
are ratings and reviews image thumbnail
product availability and finally the
site links
adding schema markup to your html is one
of the
ranking factors and with that we have
come to an end of this video on
seo tips in 2021 i hope it was
informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask anyway in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here